my parents always been very happily
married I think the reason why me and my
brother are so like normal I think we're
extremely normal we're very grounded and
normal and we don't have any like issues
we don't have any like chips on our
shoulder like me and Gideon we're good
we're healthy people and I think that's
because Mom and Dad raised us in a
healthy environment mom made dinner dad
was home at 7:30 dinner was on the table
I remember when we were younger mom
would say if we did something naughty
she'd be like just wait till your father
gets home then I'd see Dad come home and
you'd see the whites of his eyes mom
never wondered where Dad was and I
really think that's why me and Gideon
are just so normal again I think we're
normal and then we go into the real
world you know once you like leave the
nest and you see how messed up people
are and it's because divorce is so high
it's because men are having children
with multiple women women have are
having children with multiple different
men and it's all a mess and so I really
think the nuclear family is the best
thing